this short tutorial is all
about the topic of variance after this video
you will know what variance is how you
calculate it why there are two different
forms and what the difference to the
standard deviation is at the end of this
video you will then see how you can
calculate the variance of
you can easily calculate your data online if you like
you can read about the topics from this video
in our book statistics made
equal you can find the link
in the video description and with
that i would say let’s start right
away so what do the dares know now about the variance  is a measure
that indicates how much your data scatters around the
mean value, so the variance has
something to do with the scattering of data.
A simple example,
let's say you measured the height of a small
group of people
. The variance tells us how strong
our data is  spread around the mean value,
so we first have to
calculate the mean value for the m
you get the mean value simply by adding up the
height of the individual people
and dividing it by the number of people
let's say the result is a mean value of
155 cm now we want to know
how the data spread around the mean
value for this we look at the
differences between each  person to the
mean so we look at the
first person who deviates 18 centimeters
from the mean the second
person is - eight centimeters from the
mean the third - 15 the fourth 8 cm
the 59 cm and finally the sixth
person has six centimeters from  in the
mean value from we want to
get a positive value every time,
regardless of whether the person is larger or smaller
than the mean value, so
we quadri your the difference in the first
person we have 18 times 18 which is
324 in the second comes minus
8  minus 8 64 house with the third
comes
out 225 and so on and so forth
but now we are not interested in the
deviating one  ng of each individual person
from the means he has but we
want to know how big the scatter is on
average, so we add up
all the values ​​to that is
794 and then divide this by the
number of participants in our case
six so we get
132.3 3  It is very important to note
that the quarter of
yours means that the unit is no longer centimeters
but centimeters squared, so
here we have calculated the
average squares deviation
from the mean and that
is exactly the variance but slowly that is
exactly the formula for the variant, the
variance  can you calculate with this
formula here is because the number of people
in our case is 6x the size
of each person extreme is the
mean of all people
so the variance is the sum of the
squares of the deviation divided by the
number of values
for our example that means that we
the size of the first person -
calculate the mean and quarter the
size d  he second person - the
mean value and then quartering and
so on and so forth until we have reached the
last person
we then divide this by the
individuals of the person i.e. six the result is then 132 33 centimeters squared i.e. each individual person has  a certain
squares deviation from the mean value but
on average the squares
deviation from the mean value is
132 33 centimeters squared at this point
you can see why the
variance is a little more difficult to
interpret than the
standard deviation and so we come
to the next point, what is it
difference between the variance and the
standard deviation as you now have
the variance the quartered
average distance from the
mean the standard deviation is
the average distance from the
mean i.e. without the square therefore
we have one and the same formula only
for the standard
deviation the root is taken for the variance  not
others  To put it bluntly, the variance is the
pared standard deviation and the
standard deviation is the root of the
variance. Because the root of the standard deviation is taken at the
end
, you can interpret the
standard deviation more easily compared to the
variance. By
taking the root, the
standard deviation always has the unit like
the initial data in our example
centimeters the variance results from
centimeters squared for this
reason it is advisable to
always use the standard
deviation when describing your data, since interpretation is
easier here now
one thing might have caught your attention i always talk
about the standard deviation  from the
mean deviation from the mean value
but for the mean deviation I just want to
add up all the deviations and divide by the
number of participants, just like you
calculate the mean values ​​or
you are absolutely right, but there are
v  different means in the case of
standard deviation the
military mean is not used but
the root mean square would be used would the
arithmetic mean be used
we would get zero out of the standard deviation
every time so far so
good and there is one more thing
to keep in mind namely there are two easy
different forms for the variance
the difference between the equations
is that it is divided once by n and
once by the - once but why that
why there are two different formulas
usually you want to know the variance of the population
, for example
you want to know how big the  variance
of the body height of all
german professional football players is the
end now of all german
professional football players the body height
if you had you would
take this equation with 1 divided by m it is usually
not
possible to ask the entire population so
you take a random sample  and then want  you
use this sample to estimate the variance of the population
in which
case you use this formula
whenever you hate all the data and want to calculate the variance
for exactly this
data you use 1 through m you have a
sample and you want to use the variance for
the population
rush  you n - 1 if
you have created a questionnaire with the
questionnaire you have not surveyed the entire population, which is almost
never the case, so you
always use the formula on the right-hand side
just as if you are conducting a clinical study,
then you also use the
formula on  the right-hand side
to estimate the variance of the population by
default because the
statistics software solution including
datatec calculate the variance using the formula on
the right-hand side and this brings
us straight to the point of how you can
easily calculate the variance online with
datatec visitors  simply
date up de copy the data into the
tabe
lle and select the variables for which you
want to calculate the
variance then you simply
click on variance and then you will get this
output in an uncomplicated way
if you would like to read it accordingly we
would like to have a look at our
book statistics made easy with the
e-book  you with many graphics
and simple texts the basics of
statistics if you like just have a
look the link is in the
video description i hope
you liked the video and see you
next time bye